good afternoon cs19 how are you guys
doing today yay fantastic we have an
exciting class we get to talk about some
of the probability behind ethics and
machine learning and boy is this an
important
topic we've learned some pretty
interesting machine learning in CS
109 and we are currently living the
experience of watching the world contend
with smarter and smarter algorith
and it brings up two important things
I'm glad you guys know machine learning
cuz maybe you'll do something really
helpful for the world with it and also
it just feels like for us to understand
what's going on in this world we should
know the machine learning that is
impacting our society and we should be
able to see it uh look at it with a a
sophisticated lens if possible and
that's what we're going to do today okay
oh and this is like such a cute thing to
start out with I've been thinking about
like what is my own personal basis of
ethics and before we jump into this
lecture I just want to tell you where I
think I am right now um where does this
idea of human goodness come from is a
really interesting ethical question
before we jump into like our cool
lecture I want to tell you that I'm kind
of gravitating towards this uh mous
philosophy of ethics and the melanous
philosophy of Ethics says that there is
goodness in all of us there is a sprout
of goodness goodness is not something
that is given to us it's not something
that comes later in life it is in our
hearts from the beginning um and some
people feed those Sprouts so he is this
agricultural metaphor of the goodness is
a sprout within us and if you water that
Sprout it will grow and germinate into
the fully benevolent person that we are
all capable of being and he often argues
at this point by using the uh allegory
of the baby in the well if any of us saw
a baby walking towards a well if we
thought that baby was going to fall into
the well you would have this not
reflexive you know conscious but very
predictable reaction to go help that
baby and in fact all of us can just feel
uncomfortable imagining a baby falling
into well and he says this is his
example of saying there is something
hardwired about humans that has some
goodness there is that sprout in us some
people don't exhibit uh you know a
mature version of that Sprout but it's
everywhere and I just love this cuz you
guys kind of know me by now I'm like I'm
kind of an optimistic person I do see
this goodness in everybody so I do like
this ethical construct but my own
personal ethical construct is a little
bit less important than what we're going
to talk about
today the framing for today is very
simple AI is impacting Our Lives all
over the place you know it lives on our
smartphones you know there security
cameras social media all these different
facets of life we're starting to see
algorithms play a role in human
existence and therefore we must think
about Ai and how it could be
fair there's a few ways of thinking
about this one is with uh great power
comes great responsibility another way
of thinking about this there's a whole
field and set of careers in people who
are thoughtful about what fairness means
in this new phase so you know I said at
the beginning of class no matter what
your interests are there is something
you can combine with probability you
know if you're into dance you can do
dance and probability uh and and
certainly if you're into philosophy
there's a lot of room for careers in
philosophy and
probability now we do live in a time
with real work should be done and some
times the affordances of machine
learning can be helpful you know we can
all imagine Better Health Care you know
I think of my daughter who has coar
implants and like the the AI in those C
implants will make her life better um
you know we can make smart grids to be
more intelligent about how we can
balance uh electricity in this coming
electrical age um and you know maybe we
can increase access to high quality
education there's all this real work
that could be done with machine
learning but also it is worth talking
about some of the examples of
shortcomings where we can look at
deployments of machine learning think
that's not good um and some some
versions that uh show biases sometimes
uh you know computer science can hit
Beyond biases and in fact we'll talk
about this example later um and there's
a or there just case studies we can
point to where like there could have
been a better way and we're going to see
if we can come with a nice construct for
that can I give you guys learning goals
couple things let's imagine where would
we like to be when we want out of
today's class I would like you to
understand the limits of this idea of
fairness through unawareness that's
something I would like everybody to know
I'd like you guys to know these two ways
of measuring fairness and the know there
Subway of relax calibration I want all
of you guys to know that in fact those
are things that this is something you
will need for your problem set now this
isn't something that I'll test you on
but I also want you guys to walk out
with some sense of techniques and
principles to mitigate fairness issues
so that's our goal for today does that
sound
good okay let's do it there is this
other medical uh which is like how to
become a responsible scientist and not
show up in the news uh like this
researcher okay um a couple Concepts
that are going to come up in today's
class what is a protected demographic
what's the difference between
distributive harm versus quality of
service harm and then what is fairness
what what's the philosophy of procedural
versus distributive fairness and then
these different definitions of fairness
so you're going to see a whole bunch of
very technical interesting things that
come from the world of philosophy that
apply to the world of computer science
and then I did want to put up this
warning this is my own take by the way
this is a lecture made uh by Katie creel
and
myself um a lot of the research done on
fairness comes from the US especially
fairness in machine learning um and I do
think of that as a kind of funny
metabias like I we'll talk about
fairness but be mostly centered within
our own community and you can imagine
every Community has accesses of
discrimination that are worth talking
about so even though our examples do
come from the US and I would like to
highlight that the framing of what you
all learn does go beyond um the sorts of
accesses that you will see in the
US okay A little bit of review shall
we ah machine learning we've been
learning about it for a while and
particularly we've been talking about
blackbox models um where you have a
model which we can take in some inputs
make a prediction and that model is
governed by parameters we call it
blackbox model because we imagine using
it like a blackbox where you just put
your inputs in it and outputs come out
and you know particularly we've been
talking about classification algorithms
where your inputs could be some set of
features for an individual and the
output could be some sort of discret
prediction like a zero or a one for a
class
label we've talked about two major
algorithms uh we learned about naive
base and then we learned about logistic
aggression
uh I do want to tell you something that
we didn't go too deep into but is very
very interesting if you took logistic
regression some people notice that if
the input to the sigmoid is positive it
predicts a one and if the input to the
sigmoid is a negative it predicts a zero
and so you can think about this set of
points like what are all the inputs
where the input to the sigmoid is a zero
so it's perfectly between the positive
and negative and for those of you guys
who have seen this before you might
recognize that this is the description
of a straight
line so what this is telling us is that
logistic regression imagine you only had
two features because then I can
visualize it you only had features X1
and X2 and based on that you're either
going to predict a one or a zero the
idea is that logistic regression is only
able to draw a straight line between the
zeros and ones and if it can find a nice
straight line it can do a perfect job on
this task but if your points aren't
linearly separable it can't do a perfect
job does that make sense very cool way
of understanding the limitation of
logistic regression it does pretty well
but we can think about the cases where
it will break of course if you have more
than two features it's really hard to
think about this because you end up
having like a straight line in higher
dimensional space but it still has this
straight line uh sort of
property interestingly turns out naive
Bay is also creating a linear separator
in that there's no interaction between
the X the different features that are
allowed in terms of making its
prediction so both logistic regression
and naive Bays have this similar
limitation and then in last Wednesday's
class we took it to the next level we're
like well what if we want to have more
powerful predictors and we did we said
hey logistic agression you kind of look
like a cartoon model of a neuron what if
we just stacked logistic regressions on
top of logistic regressions would that
be crazy and at first the world thought
yes but then the world got powerful
computers and said not crazy
gamechanging and that is the backbone of
all modern AI a bunch of logistic
regressions put together called neural
networks it turns out these neural
networks can make predictions that are
much more sophisticated than just
straight
lines we saw them in class we talked
about how they make their predictions we
even talked about how they use chain
roll in order to gain intelligence so
you can use maximum likelihood
estimation not on just one logistic
regression but on a whole neural network
of many logistic aggressions what a time
to be alive uh and this was an
interesting thing that we pointed out in
last Wednesday's class not only can they
learn something more complicated than a
straight line
classifier when they train neural
networks on things like recognizing
faces the craziest thing happens where
the first layers start to become Edge
detectors the middle layers start to
become part detectors and final layers
start to look like ghost fa faces and
the crazy thing about that is even
though these were just getting their
weights from
mle applied with chain rule they learned
something that is so similar to how our
human brains work if you looked at our
human brains the V1 cortex is an edge
detector and if you looked at what
particular neurons are looking for it
looks a lot like that later in our brain
you find part detectors and if you
looked at what sort of inputs would most
stimulate neurons later on in your V2
cortex you would see stuff like that uh
and later on again you get these ghost
faces insane something crazy is going
on but it turns out these neural
networks while amazing are not panas and
not every example of neural networks
applied to human problems has been
successful we're going to talk about
places where this stuff is broken and in
order to do that it is worth noting that
not not every broken neural network is
equally bad uh and so let's bring in our
first idea from philosophy thank you
there are different ways of saying whoa
that model was really janky here's one
we think it is bad if a neural network
that does something wrong introduces a
quality of service harm and a quality of
service harm is one where we say this
neural network works better from certain
demographics than others so for example
maybe you have generative art or facial
recognition and it doesn't work for
everybody equally that's considered to
be bad and
harmful but not nearly as harmful as if
you had machine learning that does
something called a Distributive harm we
think that there's particular
opportunities resources or information
that are really essential like for
example getting a job or getting a loan
or getting into a school these are
really important decisions so if neural
networks start to make mistakes over
here we think of that as even more
harmful uh and then finally just to like
cap off this conversation there are
existential harms I'm not sure when
we're ready to talk about this but like
do do we need to start thinking about
when AI becomes intelligent I'm not sure
I feel like I would just be speculating
as much as anyone else but we do think
of degrees of harm um all the way from
quality of service harm to existential
harm let me give you two case studies
that give us an idea of AI producing uh
quality of service harms and
distributive Harms you guys
ready so my first case study for you is
a case study in quality of service harm
uh and it comes down to these cameras
that were actually released uh and were
a were trying to do autofocus but the
autofocus did not work if you were not
white and particularly um would make
some awful decisions uh for different
demographics how did this happen we
considered this to be a quality service
harm one way of telling the story is to
go a little bit back into the world of
understanding neural networks so I told
you the story on Wednesday of a neural
network that was trained to look at
images and tell you what's in those
images the naral network uh we got
really good at predicting you know
whether or not an image was one of a
thousand or more than a thousand or
22,000
categories but can I show you some
places where that neural network makes
mistakes and these are like a little bit
more neutral uh than what we just saw
these really really smart neural
networks that can perform almost as well
as humans make some pretty hilarious
mistakes so for example it's pretty sure
this is a sea sea lion it's pretty sure
that this is a manhole
cover what could possibly lead to this
very intelligent neural network making
those sorts of
mistakes problems with the training data
oh yeah totally but can you tell me a
little bit more than just problems cuz
you're right but it is worth getting a
little bit more deeper into
that what do you think what sort of
problems like why the manhole cover for
that particular image lack of coverage
for that specific feature um and because
it has so few data points to choose from
it can pick and choose and get noise um
yeah so it's probably not seen enough
dragon flies that's certainly the case
uh and but there's something specific
about this picture uh yes I think angle
that it's taken at um and even for the
photoes are doing that
thing yes yes yes okay so angles
definitely is part of it an idea not to
just read off the slide but I mean it
seems like texture comes into it the sea
lion has like a smooth surface and the
manhole cover is sort of like graded as
well yeah it turns out they get really
obsessed over things that humans can see
past like for example they're really
into textur so this just happened to
have a texture that looks like a manhole
cover and this happened to have a
texture from the water over here that
looked like a sea line now there is a
good argument that it's just a data
problem uh so training data can really
be a source of biases within neural
network so what you train your neural
network on really does matter there's
lots of ways of telling the story one
story is what we just saw you know it it
got confused because it saw too many uh
textures associated with man holism so
when it saw a particular texture all
always associated with
manholes here's another way though of
getting a little bit deeper into this
data problem imagine you have a
classifier and it could be linear it
could be more complicated but let's
imagine linear for
now imagine you now have a population
that has a majority group and a minority
group in the majority group here's how
you would classify class Zero from class
one but for the minority group let's say
it works pretty
differently when you put put all this
data together into your data set imagine
you're learning a linear
classifier is it going to being paying
attention to the signal that comes from
the majority group or the minority group
when it's trying to figure out some
classifier to best split the circles
from the pluses talk about what the
person next to you for a minute and then
we will talk about what will actually
happen together okay go for it I'll take
a Time chance to draw over
here
you
it's interesting to think
about
okay I so I'm sure a lot of you guys
came to something like
this it's using maximum likelihood
estimation to train and so the
likelihood Ood is going to treat each
point equally every point will have
exactly one vote uh and so because of
that because there's so many more points
voting for uh a algorithm that separates
like this than there are coming from the
minority demographic mle really wants to
just ignore that Minority demographic
and just focus on what is the overall
trend and that really comes from the
fact that Emily has whether or not
you're in the log version it has that
sum over data points or if you're in the
um the non-log version you have the
product over data points where it treat
every single data point the
same okay
so at this
point lack of data uh can be a huge
problem and in fact going back to that
camera we really do think that is one of
the biggest problems was just one group
looked like a minority to the algorithm
and then the algorithm just hadn't been
trained on enough data and was making
bad mistakes it was trained on a faces
in the wild data SP data set which was
maybe unsurprisingly 84% white and 78%
male and because of this it did very
well poorly when it was out of
distribution and actually this is
something that we've gotten much better
at they started this process of pointing
out those mistakes they took a whole
bunch of models that were in the wild
that had been published and were
actually being used and showed how they
were making bad decisions uh based on
demographics and then they produced data
sets that you can use that are much more
Bal across different contexts that
people might be coming from and once
people started training on these data
sets those particular examples that we
saw um became less prevalent so anyways
cool little story that took place here
at
Stanford now there are other levels of
harm so that was an example of quality
of service harm but things get a little
bit more serious when they affect
people's lives and that makes sense like
if you're making a decision about
whether or not somebody goes to school
or prison that's a different level of
harm if you get it wrong and here's a
case study of a Distributive harm in
AI so there is this case of St George
hospital it's a medical school and they
had a whole bunch of applicants they
have 2,500 applicants uh they would
interview approximately
625 so 3/4 people get rejected between
this stage and this stage and then
eventually they offer spots to 425 so
70% of interviewees are uh
accepted in 197 9 one of the Deans had
this great idea they said hey we've got
a lot of historical data of people who
have applied and gotten past this stage
I could train an Al a classification
algorithm to decide who is going to get
to the stage and we can just have a
computer do this whole first
pass so here is the timeline of what
happened 1982 he argues that he's built
this classifier and then he argues is
he's getting 90 to 95% classification
accuracy so when he makes a prediction
95% of the time it agrees with what a
human would have said on the panel that
sounded like high enough accuracy so um
in 1982 they started using
it then later on there is internal
review which asked why are applicants
being weighted by factors like name and
place of birth when they actually looked
into the algorithm it would be putting
weits on things that people thought
weren't that important and it led to a
review of this algorithm um and then
eventually this went to uh a ethics
hearing because um it found out that the
name and place of birth were being used
to dock points from female and
non-caucasian
applicants so I guess this story tells
us of hey when you make mistakes it is
much worse when it's affecting something
like well people end up in school
now that was just to give you a case
study of these two different harms but
along the way we have picked up some
insights we have this term in AI garbage
in garbage out which means if you have
bad data coming in you will make bad
predictions if we go back to the St
George's one one of the reasons that the
algorithm was making bias predictions is
because before the 1980s the humans were
also making bias predictions and the
algorithm learned to recreate the
garbage that it was trained
upon um similarly we can say you know
improper use of sensitive features that
algorithm really shouldn't have been
looking at things like people's names
that's a red flag that says that should
not matter for whether or not you're
ready for medical school um and then
there's this idea that it's very
believable that somebody who trained
this algorithm didn't intend to be evil
like they maybe thought they were doing
something pretty reasonable but just
having not thought it through they ended
up creating quite a lot of harm
so at this point we've just uh pointed
out a couple times of far Farm can we
get a little bit more formal about
fairness and the answer is philosophers
are so excited to tell us yes yes we can
we've been thinking about fairness for a
long time we can actually get into more
specifics about how we can call an
algorithm fair or not
fair to start this conversation it's
worth pointing out that there's two big
fields of thought for what we call
fairness one field of thought says
fairness should come from the procedure
you use they call this procedural
fairness so what is the process of your
classification and what do you do to
ensure that your algorithm doesn't rely
on unfair features that's procedural
fairness and there is another school of
thought that says well what really
matters is the outcome of the decisions
you make and so there's these two big
philosophical camps let's be fair in our
procedure or let's be fair in our
outcome let's jump into a few few
different definitions of fairness that
speak to these different philosophies
the first one speaks to procedural
fairness and a lot of people
historically subscribe to this being a
good idea the motivating idea for this
first definition of fairness fairness
through unawareness is the best way to
stop
discrimination is to stop discriminating
based on race weights that's a chief
justice Roberts that's a little bit
obscure so let's unpack it it's saying
that if you're making a decision if you
know nothing about somebody's sensitive
features then you'll make a good
decision that's the idea of unawareness
be unaware of the demographics and
you'll be fair with respect to
demographics how to do it gets a little
bit more interesting you know the first
idea um is to exclude sensitive features
so if you're making a prediction it is
procedurally unfair if you're looking at
any of these protected demographics and
the second idea is we also have to be
thoughtful about proxies let's jump into
that a little bit
it is worth also noting what do I mean
when I say protected groups in the US
there are legally protected groups in a
lot of different important um uh in a a
lot of different important
cases the idea of a protected group
often means that regardless of people's
race color national origin religion age
or sex sexual orientation physical or
mental disability um or reprisal uh
people should be getting Fair decisions
made for them uh and reprisal I think is
like you know if somehow somebody had
been harmed in the past they shouldn't
be discriminated in making in the
decisions that are made against them in
the future this is the definition that
comes from the Equal Employment
Opportunity Act but this same definition
lives in a lot of places uh in legal
code for the US like for example housing
and
Loans so this seems pretty reasonable
but can we jump into how fairness
through unawareness can be surprisingly
difficult let's take some people who you
know live across the street
Facebook they do ads and at some point
they were making people would be
publishing ads on Facebook for housing
housing is important because it's
legally protected with respect to those
protected
demographics now I've never made an ad
in Facebook but here's how I understand
it works when you go to make an ad at
some point you had an option of saying
give me
lookalikes and what lookalikes mean
would be like you would create your ad
and be like here's five people I want my
ad to go to people who look like these
five people um and they did this for all
their ads and at some point in
2018 some people said that is not a good
way to do advertisements for housing
because advertisements for housing are
not supposed to be biased based off of
these protected demographics and
Facebook had to change their algorithm
and so Al Facebook made this change they
said we're going to do fairness through
unawareness we can do lookalikes but our
algorithms are not going to look at any
of the protector Grog graphic we're not
going to look at the age that the look
like we're not going to look at the
gender the look like we're going look at
the relationship status we're not going
to look at the religious views the
schools the political views any of this
we're not going to look at any of that
you can still give look likes but we
will be unaware of their demographics
and therefore it will be
fair okay well anyway we'll jump into
this but turns out long story is no and
I'm going to give you guys a second to
try and think about why now this is a
funny uh plot it comes from a paper
which basically said hey Facebook your
new lookalike thing still is um able to
pull People based on
demographics so what they did is can you
try to flip this X and Y AIS cuz the x
is what the researchers were controlling
they would make
lookalikes with different fractions of
men and they did this in the old version
of Facebook and in the new version of
Facebook that didn't look at
demographics so you know in this set of
look likes there' be no men at all and
in the top set look like there would be
100% men and then this is the yellow one
is when they were looking uh when they
were looking at demographics and you
would actually get zero men you know and
men that looked proportional to the
lookalike uh distribution but when
Facebook didn't look at demographics
look how closely it was able to produce
the same fraction of men as in the
lookalike set even though the algorithm
was not looking at any def demographics
at all how is this possible algorithm
doesn't look at whether or not somebody
is a
male but it can figure out a population
with the exact same proportion of men as
in the lookalike population a little bit
of mystery but a mystery that you guys
could figure out if you talked with the
person next to you for about a minute
okay so think about that how could
Facebook still be pulling out the right
prop or the lookalike percentage of
men
e
okay how does this happen they said
don't look at gender they said don't
look at age I'm not looking at your age
I'm not looking at anyone have a idea
yes
iures Associated users do you want to
give me one that you think maybe you
could hypothesize might be Associated
maybe like shaving products oh yeah like
do you like shaving products
yes uh you know everybody shaves um
maybe like your movie selection I'm not
saying that you know we don't all like
the same movies but maybe if you're like
all Jurassic parks and you know Star
Wars then maybe that can just influence
but if you put enough of these features
together like you know maybe this
doesn't tell you for sure and maybe this
doesn't tell you for
sure but there's this interesting result
which is as we add more and more
features like you tell me more and more
about a person even if you don't tell me
their demographics I can predict their
demographics better and better and
better like as you give me more of these
things and more of them leak some
information about demographics you put
it all together and by the time you're
Facebook and you've told me everything
about this person like their friends
their likes um you know their history on
The Social Network then you have a
really good way of guessing their
demographics without being told and we
call those proxies yes why would we add
all that redund data in the first place
so like what what does your movie
interest have to do with wanting to rent
a house good question it should not I
agree with you but uh the look likes
algorithm did that because people would
do ads for things that were not houses
like maybe you want to give ads for I
don't know you're selling like the
coolest pet app and you want lots of
people to buy it and you think somehow
like people's likes are going to uh be
really important in predicting who's
going to buy or p app I'm not trying to
sell the pet app it's staying free
forever just for 109 U but does that
make sense is because it was for the ads
platform and they thought these things
would be important for ad Sellers
Facebook their customer are the ad
buyers yes don't they have our pictures
they have our pictures I believe the
look alikes yeah might have even be
using the pictures possibly I don't know
but if they did that would be a really
strong signal maybe you wouldn't need
you know like 80 features to predict to
somebody's
mail good good question I owe you Mander
but come forward after
class okay I have a question yes
so the previous slide so how much
teachers how much information can I tell
Without Really compromising when
you ah okay that's a deep question so
the question was how much information
could I give you without compromising
your your proxy it depends on the
feature itself and if we had a set of
features we could talk about you know
the probability that somebody could um
predict this demographic you know what I
would probably do to answer that
question a simple way I would take the
features and i' take the data I have and
then I'd predict I'd build a deep
learning or logistic regression model
that would try and predict the
demographics uh and I would see how
accurate it got and that's how I would
test but depends on the features and if
you have the the right proxies it's just
not that many such a good question I
love it okay so at this point in our
story we would like to get formal about
fairness and the first natural thing was
well we'll be fair by just not looking
at the demographics but it turns out
that's really hard fairness through
unawareness is really difficult to do
which maybe invites us to start thinking
about this other philosophy of maybe we
can be fair but by looking at outcomes
so we can try fairness if not through
unawareness then fairness through
awareness let's be aware of demographics
and make sure that our algorithms are
fair that way now we've talked about
this in section before so this is a
little bit of a review but it's review
worth uh restating because you're going
to need it for your problem
sets if you have a classification
algorithm one of the things you could do
is you can build this joint distribution
table this is a joint distribution
between three random variables which you
can calculate based off your training
data so one random variable is for any
point in the uh training data set you
can calculate D which is going to be
your protected demographic now there
could be more than two groups but just
to keep it clear or simple we can say we
have two different demographics d0 and
D1 but because you have a training
algorithm there's other variables you
have access to so G AKA y hat could be
your guess and G is the guess of your
model so if you put this trading data
through the model that you're evaluating
if G is zero it's going to guess that
the label is zero and if G is one your
algorithm's guessing that the label is
one and then there is a separate thing
the guess of the algorithm is not always
correct so because this is training day
you also have access to the truth AKA Y
and the truth could say you know in fact
this out or the true output of this
algorithm was zero or in fact the true
output of this algorithm is
one you could take all your training
data and you could have a a joint table
because you could think about these
random variables
together from these random variables
there are many definitions of fairness
through awareness we're going to just
talk about a couple of them that are the
most commonly used the first one is hey
maybe I'll think about your algorithm as
being fair if it satisfies parity and if
you read the algorithm definition of
parity it gives a problemistic
definition it says the probability that
you guess
one for somebody from one demographic is
the same as the probability that you
guess one for somebody of another
demographic so regardless of people's
background your algorithm has the same
probability of predicting a one and
maybe we think that this is a good sign
that the algorithm is making Fair
decisions but it's not the only good
sign a different good sign is that you
know I want condition on Dem Graphics a
different thing to be true the thing
that I want to be true is that g equals
T now that's different from saying g
equals 1 this is saying that g equals T
what's the difference yeah the parody uh
thing on the board I believe differs
from what's on this slide am I missing
one
here better yeah yes sorry so is it
saying that the algorithm predicts
correctness regardless of demographic or
regardless of whether demographic is
included yeah so this is saying
regardless of the true demographic of
the person the algorithm is just as
likely to make the right decision so not
like whether we include demographic or
not no matter what it could be included
it could be not included but the outcome
is that correctness is not conditionally
different based on um demographic you
could say that it is conditionally
independent of demographic yes question
I was asked yes it's independent yeah so
you know knowing demographic won't
change your belief in whether or not the
algorithm get it right and this first
one parody says knowing the demographic
won't change your belief that it's going
to predict a one those are subtly
different things yeah is there a
situation where we wouldn't want it to
be the
same like would it in some cases
actually make sense and be beneficial to
actually match the
true yeah there are cases where you
might say uh um you
know for this one particularly you say
that you know for different demographics
maybe there is a different underlying
rate so an algorithm that's always
predicting one independently of
demographic then maybe it's inaccurate
because there's a different base rate
but some people say that even if there's
a different base rate that might still
be something worth aiming for because
we'd like our society to move towards
this um but then this is a little bit
more saying you know there could be a
different base rate so you could be
predicting g equals 1 in different rates
but you're correct the same amount of
time and they're different
philosophically and there's certainly
been algorithms where I've seen people
debate very hard about what they
consider to be fairness because it does
turn out that not all these fairness can
be satisfied together you sometimes have
to make a decision of what fairness you
think you're going to be going for and
that really depends on the case um I do
want to not a little bit more that there
is a legal standard for what what allow
what level of independ we're looking for
I know things are Independence is binary
you're either independent or not but
people do allow these things to be
slightly different in some legal uh
situations so for example the US has
this legal standard of disperate impact
which says an algorithm is acting um in
a biased way with respect to calibration
and that's not saying that these two
things have to be exactly equal it
allows the ratio to be you know either
this ratio has to be greater than equal
to one minus some Epsilon sorry that
should be 0.2
um and regardless of which thing goes on
the numerator and we think that if this
numerator is close enough to being one
then we think that this follows under uh
calibration according to Legal
standards
now there is this historical story which
is not that historical it's not that old
back in the day there was this algorithm
that people were using California and
Florida to predict whether or not
somebody would commit a crime again and
this is very important because it was
used in courts in order to decide if
people would get lenient sentences or
stronger sentences uh and I think also
to decide whether or not people would be
given
bail so this algorithm which has the
name Compass was being used in in these
states making predictions but regardless
of whether or not you measured
calibration or parity it was doing a bad
job and that the the Gap was very large
between uh black inmates and white
inmates
so at this point I do think fairness
through awareness has a lot of strengths
fairness through unawareness is very
difficult fairness through
awareness has this idea that like okay
we're going to pay attention to
demographics and try and be fair but it
does have weaknesses that are also worth
pointing out the first one is you have
to make a stance about what your
definition of fairness is and there's
more than these two there are like 17
definitions there's people in CS and
philosophy who come up with new
definitions all the time um and so you
have to choose what fairness means to
you there is this more subtle harm
though that can come from fairness
through awareness that is worth pointing
out um and this was uh came out in a
paper by Cynthia dor and Omar reingold
who are professors here in the Cs
Department um of this self-fulfilling
prophecy challenge that can come through
fairness through awareness
the idea is let's say a
classifier is made to be really good at
one of these definitions of
fairness if it turns out that pursuing
that fairness means that the algorithm
is a lot worse at choosing strong
candidates in different groups then you
might see a quality of service disparity
later on which might lead people to look
at differences in the groups and assume
that there is a stronger difference than
are between the groups which can change
people's mindsets to think that some
group is stronger than the other which
they call allocation dispar uh disparity
uh and so there is an argument for
there's a lot more Nuance to this uh
though a lot of though that's something
worth keeping in mind this is still the
state-ofthe-art that a lot of people go
towards when we think about
fairness okay so where are we in cs19
yeah great question yeah I was just
wondering so I mean in all of these I
understand that not consider demographic
information like Race For example would
be really important especially if you're
looking at like crimes but if you're
looking at something that's not like
humans discriminating against humans but
like diseases discriminating based on
genetics or something like that how do
you draw a line between not including
race because you don't necessarily have
enough data but still that being a major
factor that contributes to different
disease outcomes for people that's a
good question so okay I like let's think
about the disease thing often fairness
comes down to like decisions made by
humans so let's imagine in the world of
disease what's a decision that humans
could be
making like whether to treat or not I
guess yeah okay let's say whether to
treat or not so um in this world whether
to treat or not is a decision that
you're making is a decision that we
could think through the fairness
construct um okay okay so now that I'm
in this world what was the question
sorry so I mean I guess like for example
a doctor is trying to use this to decide
should I treat this patient or not and
maybe it's shown that for this subass of
patients this race of patients this
treatment doesn't work as well for
whatever reason that's what data shows
that might actually be true but if we're
not ignoring that then we're potentially
putting those people at harm yeah so
that's a good argument I think for you
should not be using parody in that case
uh you should not be saying treat at the
same rate for the two different groups I
think that's still an argument where you
might want to say you're calibrated
which is I'm not going to treat at the
same rates because we know that there
might be different effects uh yet I want
the accuracy of my decision to be the
same so if I decide to treat and treat
was the right decision you know that's
plus one for accuracy and if I decide to
treat but that was the wrong decision
that's a zero for accuracy and we want
that rate to be the same right so in
calibration you're still like if you're
training an algor you can still use
demographic data to train
it yeah potentially gu calibration
doesn't speak about the procedure you
use it just speaks about the outcomes
though is it possible to try and do both
of these at the same time absolutely and
that I feel like that's maybe a good
practice like don't try and use
demographics in your prediction and then
make sure that your outcomes are somehow
Fair even if demographics have been
shown to impact ah okay um no maybe that
is a case where you say like using
demographics could be important so maybe
yeah maybe in the particular case you
brought up that might be a good example
for we want fairness through awareness
and we particularly want calibration and
not
parity yes if a big model is going to
infer demographics through proxies why
not just include it at the beginning of
the the model if we're so sure based on
these like common considerations that it
will be reconstructed so I mean going
back to Facebook they're legally not
allowed to so like you're not supposed
to be looking at demographics when
making the decision U because the law
was built around procedural fairness so
even okay so your question is hey these
algorithms are going to build
proxies should we just throw in
demographics and I'd say that the arms
race goes in the other direction we
shouldn't include the demographics and
we should be mindful about proxies and
we should think of ways that we can deal
with the proxies because it turns out
there are things we could do want to
learn more about those okay let's jump
into it okay so at this point in class
we've said hey machine learning is an
interesting tool but it's possible to
create harms we've talked about two
specific types of harms we could talk
about then we said okay we'd like to be
fair and so that whatever harm if we're
going to possibly have harms though it'd
be great if we had zero harms uh we
should be fair and we've talked about
three versions of fairness fairness
through unawareness and then we've got
parity and
calibration now at this point though I
think it's nice to leave our story on
the note of what could we possibly do
about
it so here are some Pro tips so one of
the pro tips is being balanced in your
training data that comes from our first
set of stories you know if you're going
to be training something that does
facial recognition try and represent all
people uh in your training data there's
this other thing that's growing in the
world of AI which is being very
transparent about where your blackboxes
come from so if you make a blackbox
algorithm there's now this thing that
you can attached to it called a model
card and it tells everything like you
know who are you making this model what
is your intended use what are the
factors that go into it how did you
evaluate your model what was the
training data that you allowed on it uh
and what was the quantitative analysis
like what are all the uh measures you've
done maybe about Fair parody uh
calibration so this is becoming uh
standard and then here's a funny little
story that actually starts in cs1 that's
kind of interesting one of the things
you could do is
you could ask can we train the bias out
so back to your
question if you include demographics of
course it can make decisions based on
demographics if you exclude demographics
it might make decisions based on proxies
but can we build an algorithm that tries
to remove out those proxies uh and that
was a question that two seniors at
Stanford uh former CS 109 students were
interested in they're like can we remove
these proxies so they looked at Compass
they actually got there is a public data
set now on compass on decisions it has
made and in compass it's a the inputs
look like all sorts of data about an
inmate it has their zip code their past
crimes their age lots of inputs like
that and then the prediction is
recidivism are they going to commit a
crime again now first of all when I talk
about these inputs a whole bunch of red
flags should go off be like why do you
care about their zip coid why is that
going to make you make a good decision
and just to you guys this was actually
used in the state of California and
Florida now
compass from this data we can show was
very biased whether or not you measure
bias in calibration or in parity you
want these gaps to be zero because the
gaps are the difference between the size
of your equations so the bigger the gaps
the bigger problem you have and they had
pretty big gaps so these two students
said okay what if we tried to be
creative and came up with a way to
remove the bias that was in this Compass
algorithm and so they built a two-step
neural network the first neural network
was the prediction and this was
recreating something like Compass you
would take in the inputs and then you
would predict out whether or not
somebody would recidivate but then they
had a second neural network that would
take the output of the first neural
network and then try and predict
demographic out and they said if you
train this so that you do really well on
model one so likelihood is really high
on model one but then they said make
likelihood really low on the second one
so you're this combined model should be
really good at making its prediction but
very bad at pulling out demographics and
the theory was if you did this then you
could remove some of the proxies that
exists within the
data it worked very well so they ended
up with a model that was just as
accurate but they were able to remove
calibration gaps and parody gaps but my
favorite thing about this paper was they
did all these cool things and then
they're big claim in the paper from the
beginning to the end was yes we can do
this but you should not be using
blackbox algorithms to make reation
predictions and you should absolutely
not be using these features like zip
code shouldn't matter um and it should
be something that we can be much more
thoughtful yes judges have been biased
but biased algorithms are not the
direction we want to go towards and
particularly they picked out this idea
of using a blackbox algorithm because
it's something that defendants couldn't
argue against if the blackbox algorithm
just said like yep you're committing a
crime again no I'm just joking you
haven't committed any crimes but I'm as
an example um and you can't argue again
you're like the neural Network's wrong
you're like prove it you're like oh look
at the weights the weights are wrong and
uh it becomes really unfair to the
person to argue against a blackbox
algorithm which kind of brings us back
to an idea we saw earlier in class
neural networks are great but people
can't really argue against them black
boxes might be very accurate making
predictions but you can't understand or
figure out how it's making its decisions
you know there's some things we can do
some nice little tricks we can do to try
to understand what the neural network is
doing but the long story short is
understanding a complicated Black Box
can be as hard as understanding how a
human makes a decision that's less true
for beian networks you know basian
networks this thing we learned about
earlier where you have variables and you
have conditional probabilities between
the variables if somebody had an
algorithm that was making prediction
using a evasion Network it's a lot
easier for somebody to say hey this is
why your algorithm is wrong in my case
because even though I have this variable
this conditional probability is wrong
for
me um okay so that's a nice little aside
so one of the things you could do is
maybe you could try and train out bias
but you should always be careful about
what task you're solving actually maybe
I should have put that in here how come
I didn't put that in there it's like one
of the most important things like choose
the task you're working on think about
what the world really needs and can you
make something that will make the world
a better place like for example like you
think about the person who made the gar
detector based on people's photos is
that actually what the world needs you
imagine like what if instead of doing
all that intellectual work we put that
intellectual work into making better
smart grid so that we can better balance
Powers maybe that's the most important
thing uh but anyways uh here's a fun
little story though um one of the
interesting things is you will go on
from here and some of you guys will go
work in tech companies and it's
interesting to think about what
responsibilities we can have and even if
you're an Academia OR tech companies
what uh responsibility can we have if
we're uh in those roles here's a nice
little case study that's quite
interesting this is from a while ago
it's in
polaroid so back in the day do you guys
know Polaroid cameras like from the
shake it shake it shake no anyways okay
you take a photo it would print it you
shake the photo you actually doesn't
matter if you shake it over time it
develops and you get to see it in like
10 seconds later anyways Polaroid was a
popular American company
um originally they only had one flash uh
and the idea was that it didn't really
work with the single flash that they had
on people who are not white so it was
really built to work for people who are
white but then Polaroid turns out uh was
also selling it to the South African
government and they made a feature for
the South African government to make the
flash work um so that it could capture
uh better uh black skin tones better um
and it was used by the aparti government
to build these pass books that were like
a central part of discrimination uh in
aparti South Africa uh and the
interesting story about this is this
would have kept on going except for an
engineer who worked at Polaroid who
brought this delight and said hey this
is wrong we should talk about this and
that's how change happened it came from
inside the company um okay we're going
to talk about a little bit more but I
thought this would be a great time for a
good pedagogical pause so we've talked
about fairness we've talked about harms
we talked about what you can do about it
uh and then I'll I'll just tell you a
little about my thoughts on uh ethics on
my own okay so take two minutes and I'll
come back and we'll continue our
conversation thank you guys so much uh
for following along so
far
e
okay let's bring it on back for the home
stretch of this
lecture okay post pedagogical pause
let's go back to learning goals so
learning goals you know the first thing
we talked about in terms of formal
definitions of fa fairness was fairness
through unawareness and I hope you guys
understand why fairness through
unawareness is a little more more
complicated that Facebook example really
drove that home because there could be
lots of proxies if you wanted to make a
decision just not including demographics
is often not enough the second learning
goal know the two two ways that we talk
about in CS 109 of measuring fairness so
you know hopefully this is making a
little bit more sense um and you know
even with this uh as stct version of the
relax
calibration uh and then we just recently
talked about some techniques that we
have for mitigating fairness
issues now when I was thinking about
this
lecture I came to this decision that I
don't think a lot of computer scientists
want to be evil I just I just don't I've
seen a lot of people I feel like a lot
of people have maybe it's this menes in
me I believe there's the Sprout of
goodness in everybody uh though I do
think about the blind spot more and more
and let me tell you a story that you
might have heard of and you can let me
know uh if you haven't heard of it if
you haven't then certainly I think a
story we should all
know my idea is that even though we've
got this Sprout of goodness in us well
intention people can still break things
at scale especially while moving fast
and the story that really struck me and
actually when this developed I think it
was kind of a phase change for me as a
computer scientist I was like oh we must
be so much more thoughtful like I don't
think anyone meant to do harm here but
real harm was done let's take a pause
and think about what we're doing and
there's a story of free basic just
quickly who here knows the story of the
harm from free basic a couple okay this
is going to be a good story to hear so
the story starts with this product that
Facebook wanted to give it was called
free Basics and the idea was we're going
to give free internet to people around
the world and that's a good start be
like yeah getting people access to
Internet feels like a good thing now
maybe because Facebook wanted to get
something out of it or maybe for other
reasons they made fa the intermit be
delivered through Facebook like we'll
give you free internet but it comes
through Facebook so like Facebook is
really the internet that you
get this was deployed in a few countries
uh deployed in Sri Lanka it was deployed
um I think in Kenya no actually not in
Kenya it but it was deployed in mmar and
when it's deployed in Myanmar you had a
country where a lot of people didn't
have access to Internet and all a sudden
almost everyone hacks us to internet but
it was internet mediate through Facebook
so like everybody had a smartphone now
that could open up Facebook and you can
get access to it Myanmar had a military
hun and the military hun started a
misinformation campaign against a
particular Muslim minority in the
country called aringa a lot of
misinformation now we know a lot about
misinformation at the time it was a
little bit nor novel but you can imagine
all these people who didn't have much
access to the internet before now have
it and now are faced with a very
sophisticated misinformation
campaign but to add fuel to the fire
Facebook only had two moderators for the
entire country of Myanmar who could
speak Burmese so they had just Unleashed
free Basics lots of people were using it
a huge misinformation campaign starts
and there's just not enough people
paying attention to realize it it led to
a genocide you know we'll talk about
causality in a second but the genocide
that ensued afterwards was really awful
millions of people uh displaced
uh and the UN whenever there's a
genocide they have a mission to try and
figure out what happened and the UN
concludes that this Facebook free Basics
was a critical component in leading up
to this genocide um and so I think they
say the role of soci social media is
significant Facebook has been a useful
instrument for those seeking to spread
hate in a context where for most users
Facebook is the internet although
improved in recent months the response
of Facebook has been slow and
ineffective and you know I think this is
a when this happened it was such a
drastic harm like we'd thought about I
I'd seen examples of small harms medium
harms and then all of a sudden this was
like that's a big harm and I don't think
anyone on Facebook was like yes genocide
we're going to do it right that's not
what people were thinking I think it was
just a blind spot right they're like
we're going to give Internet it's going
to be great it's going to go through
Facebook that'll be fantastic um you
know why moderate that much and they
just didn't see this big misinformation
problem and what it could possibly lead
to and so you know you can imagine
imagine this move fast and break things
mentality though seemed really exciting
at the beginning really came into
conflict with reality when they started
to see these big blind spots and I think
that's also especially true at scale you
know Facebook was still just used in
universities probably wouldn't be facing
consequences like genocide and suddenly
at scale when you make have blind spots
it can certainly be worse Facebook has
been asked what's the answer to this by
lots of people you know we've seen
misinformation not just in Myanmar uh
and there answer interestingly is that
the only way we can prevent hate is
better machine learning and I'm not you
know we can all have opinions on that
but it's quite interesting to think that
um you know scaled computers can be the
problem and then the claim could be that
scales computers could be the solution
though I think some people some
intelligent people could argue that
maybe this is just a way to uh get
around not actually addressing the
issue but the point of this wasn't
really just to dump on Facebook the yeah
I do think though if I could drive home
a point it's that I don't think anyone
that I've met in the field of computer
science really wants to do harm but we
should be thoughtful about our blind
spots you know maybe it's um whether or
not we're predicting somebody gets
admitted to a school or whether or not
we're trying to give input internet to
other people uh we should be humble in
that if we're building something that
will affect a lot of people's lives we
should think about what are all the
things the unknown unknowns that we
might be facing
uh and then I do want this is like a
little bit of a personal thing but I
would like to highlight one blind spot
that I'm trying to contend with like I
think many of us are trying to contend
with this is a computer science blind
spot that I I worth bringing up you guys
know this story hopefully you know the
story because it's becoming a little bit
more popular bitcoin's using a lot of
energy um and you know if you think
about it in terms of hashes per second
it's a lot if you think in terms of
carbon dioxide in the environment it's a
lot too and despite the fact that we're
seeing more evidence that this is a
problem it's really hard for us to look
at this blind spot straight on and you
one piece of evidence I'd Point towards
that is that we teach a lot of
blockchain but you know I don't think
Bitcoin and the effect on the
environment is something that even shows
up in an ethics class on Stanford and I
will update the slide once somebody
tells me that has changed uh and it's
not too hard to see why increased CO2
could be a problem this is like CO2 in
the atmosphere and you can see it's
become quite large since humans have
started contributing it's not too hard
to know the physics of why CO2 will make
our world warmer you know we know the
fact that it can have a cool video if
you're curious um it's not too hard to
know that the impacts would be really
harsh if we have a large change in
temperature you know we've seen the
world or we have ways of understanding
what the world was like uh when it was
quite a lot colder and there was a lot
less or the
the change in temperature was a lot
smaller and you can imagine when we get
to the point where the change in
temperature is quite deviant from what
it was in the historical average that it
could be something really
scary and one of the reasons it's not
too hard to imagine is that we're
already starting to see impacts like in
California fires and droughts but other
places you know like hurricane EDI
impacted over 3 million people they
weren't very used to getting huge
hurricanes in
mosambique one of the reasons I think
that this is such a blind spot is I
think a lot of people in the world are
not versed in the language that you're
now versed in I think the challenge of
climate change is filled with
uncertainties you know you have to think
about future amounts of uh CO2 you have
to think about what this will do to the
environment the climate sensitivity and
then on top of that you have to think
about how that will impact people and
these could be future people in places
far
away and even though there's a lot of
uncertainties one of the take away from
CS 109 is that's not the end of the
story you can reason under uncertainty
you can make good decisions based on
uncertain probis distributions that you
might have access
to but I am also going to acknowledge
that maybe this is less of a blind spot
um and do you guys ever feel like it's
just hard to do something about it like
I can tell you climate change is a
problem but then like what are we going
to do about it and you felt like
that there is a thing that they're doing
for Bitcoin specifically or on E they
like s steak yes that's very interesting
so
point is that they have actually started
to address this like for ethereum they
switched to proof of stake from proof of
work but Bitcoin has not Bitcoin has and
actually there's something really
interesting to that I was thinking why
can't Bitcoin switch to proof of state
so there's this idea of something that's
a little less Democratic but will not
have this huge environmental consequence
you could do this for any
blockchainbased coin and Bitcoin doesn't
change why doesn't Bitcoin
change hard to change it's completely
decentralized it's like you know there's
no one in control of Bitcoin there's no
one I feel like if any one person was in
control of Bitcoin you'd be like yo look
at all the CO2 and they're like yeah
that sucks let's change that immediately
but the great idea of decentralization
seems to have hit this problem of like
there's an obvious thing that we should
fix but decentralized we can't make that
change um anyways it's something that I
reflect on a lot as I get deeper into
thinking about decentralized education
but that's a different story um you know
there is this philosophy that I
sometimes find myself in which is like
with regards to climate change like
can't we just wait and see what happens
uh and man I I this is I'm in such an
uncomfortable place I've convinced
myself that I can't say that I've
benefited too much I produced more CO2
than the average person in the world um
it's really unfair for me to say like oh
I benefit from all this and then I'm
just going to wait and see what happens
especially because with I I'm not a
wealthy person am a professor um but
with the meager amounts of wealth I've
accumulated which is more than most
people in the world I probably won't be
affected by the results as much so I've
benefited from burning CO2 and I
probably won't be affected by the worst
changes in climate change because I
could move if I needed to um you know
California might not be hit as hard as
places that maybe didn't burn as much
CO2 so isn't it totally unfair of Chris
to say I'm just going to wait and see
what
happens and and there's ways of telling
the story you know like you can imagine
this is a very extreme example um but
you know there's a lot of people after
World War II who ask the question you
know what was the problem with
bureaucrats in Hitler's Empire and
there's a lot of people who are like you
know what I'm just going to wait and see
what happens that was a common idea of
like let's just see how this thing
develops so instead of ending on that
note I'm trying to think for myself what
can I do and maybe this is interesting
for you guys thinking about what can we
do I've decided on an individual level
it's really unfair because I could cut
all my CO2 emissions and that just won't
change things there's big companies
there's big nation states that are
producing so much CO2 that my change on
individual level is hard and then boy do
I wish I could affect the nation state
scale actually I don't really want
to but it would be cool if I could be
like hey just this one thing why don't
we just like figure out this whole CO2
let's make a lot of clean energy it'll
be fantastic if I could I would but um
you know I don't live in that world but
I do think for a lot of us there is a
sweet spot in the middle of community
and so that brings me back to the
Bitcoin thingy like maybe this as
computer scientists who are at Stanford
therefore have a lot of clout you know
maybe we can start thinking about ways
to talk about uh this blind spot that
might exist around uh the proof of work
that is behind the blockchain in
Bitcoin uh and then this is a very small
thing as computer scientists if we had a
perfectly clean grid every time you run
an algorithm you don't have to worry
about it you can go to sleep happy and
be like it's going to be doing a bunch
of hashes but I know that hash is
powered by the wind uh and so I think
all of us could sleep a lot better if we
could get uh a clean Grid in California
and in our other
locals and then certainly I don't like
to think about AI as a pan I think we
should dress our problems that are
rooted uh in in things that are outside
of AI sometimes with human
institutions and yet there's probably
really cool problems to work on in the
world of AI like I've seen people who
are going to predict you know the
electrical spikes that happen when
people plug in electrical vehicles and
if you figure this problem out then you
could really reduce the impact you could
predict buildings that are using a lot
more CO2 and they probably not heated
well so you could retrofit them so
there's a lot of cool things that we
could do and if any of you guys do that
you rock and you should tell me about it
okay now to end this lecture can I just
give you guys a small thing to do
because ethics is a complicated thing I
can come and give you formal definitions
I can give you some case studies but I
really think that the work belongs in
our hearts um so I'm not going to give
you any more homework than I already
have but if I could give you something
to do after this lecture it'd be to give
yourself some space maybe I should just
put a period here man you guys work hard
I really respect how hard you guys work
at Stanford you know like you're trying
to do all your classes you're trying to
maintain all your friendships and be
there for each other and actually just
giving oneself space in general is great
like put away our phones and like
connect with yourself is always a good
thing uh and maybe give yourself some
space and and then reflect on what's
your own sense of what is right cuz one
of the things I've learned by working
with wonderful students like yourselves
is you know you guys have in you and
what I really believe in your sense of
we right and if you're thoughtful about
it not only will you guys do wonderful
things uh I think we you'll do wonderful
and fair things uh and you know both
what is right and also how can you craft
a life well-lived with respect to what
you think is right uh okay I appreciate
you guys so much thank you so much come
back next week we have just two more
lectures and then we're done oh fin
cheers CS